and for Chicago Jason Dickinson will take
the opening face off with Bard watching
from the bench and it's controlled by zaka the
starting lineups brought to you by Taco Bell
and now kinsky the 19-year-old Senator hoping
for a tip from Lucas reel who's still looking
for his first point of the Year pointless Drew
games skated the other way now by ptra dumped
it back for Kevin Shater Patra down low on a
stop a by morzin a big hole in the middle of
the ice and nobody really expected much from
the 19-year-old ptra at Camp except he scored
the first game so he got another game he played
really well he got another game and pretty soon
he's on the opening night roster a really
headyy clever player to take it away from
radish ruins trying to counter quickly a
centering fever makoy and it's pked Away
by The Stick of morazzi and cleared by radish
it's Bard at the top of the left Circle down
low trying to jam it out in front Perry it was
Johnson stationed on front B turnover theard
scores a terrible turnover right on of the
Stick of Bard and he rocketed one pass Swan
his third NHL goal two of them against
Boston Bruins have control of the puck
as Perry tries to go through the front of
the net Coyle wants to pass this to Derek
forber forber doesn't think the Puck's coming
to him and it turns out coil's pass is right
on the T and Bard powders this pass Jeremy
Swan who's not expecting this to be a shot
on goal a half a second earlier over the
glove quick release perfectly placed and
it's one nothing on Bard's third Bost is us the
coach's challenge for offside prior to the goal
M well you know most often when they're
challenging like this they've got a pretty
good idea that it's offside before he does see
that's fine because as the puck gets there his
he's already broken the plane of the line I
believe X number of seconds before the goal
upon further video review was determined the
play was offside we have no goal frezer at
the box to 706 maybe another weapon to his
Arsenal Boston at the edge and shot attempts
offensive zone time neither team a power
play goal obviously and it's Chicago with
the man Advantage a minute and 37 to start the
period remaining that's down to a minute and
27 now here's Seth Jones played more than half
the first period was on for 10 minutes and 25
seconds Cory Perry slides it in deeper Bard going
after Brandon Carlo there first for Boston Bruins
can't clear kept in by Jones Perry now Bard on the
other side by the right Circle and shot to Fleck
it it's free out in front Bard and it blocked by
forber poked ahead but not out by makoy gonado
powers to the front and had a great chance stopped
by San and I think Ray that's an example what the
coaches have been talking to him about here's van
rdik now cutting in knocked down by the glove of
morazzi atin at age 34 and rdik finds the seam and
he doesn't get out into the open Ice very often
most of his damage is from the hash marks down and
he wants to bring morzac across to morazi's right
but morazi's in good position he keeps his glove
out front Peter morazzi was out R to the corner by
Felino Frederick suers one and a point blank shot
from Coyle stopped by morazzi he's very pleased
with ginsky very coachable 19-year-old says he
retains information very well you only have to
tell him something once score flipped from the
point by shatton Kirk might have been tipped in
route look like Saka might have tipped it
and Boston has the lead one to nothing 21
goals a career high last year Jake de brusk
to shaton Kirk and look at wide open in front
of the net is zaka he gives it the old Beaver
tap the little tap on the ice for shaton Kirk
to deliver this Puck the Puck's in a perfect
position and Zak's tip beats Peter moric up
high it's Kevin shaton Kirk's first point
Marian turned it over and tried to take it
back from Donado here's kachuk trying to cut in
and he put it on net Matt grizzli now with under
four minutes to go in the second period one
nothing Boston on a p zaka goal de brusk put
it on net makavo through traffic not sure moric
saw that one now grizzling de brusk had it pop
over his stick here's a chance for radish played
it off for a to se out in front reel still can't
buy one the turnover it leads to a three on two
and reel's going to make a nice little tow drag
when he gets this puck right around the defender
makoy stick and he's dead center but his shot also
was dead center and Berard I think we have this
Vision that he can do that but he just can't he
needs some help they don't have the pocket off
tonight exceptionally popular Lich is off to
a good start face off one by Boston it's a flex
to Kiki looking for a tip from debrus ptra came
to help room for shaton Kirk that's blocked
out in front by Jason Dickinson and s in by
Kinski of course Chicago without Taylor Hall
the former Boston Bruin who was traded over to
the Hawks in the off season aggravated a shoulder
injury on Saturday night here's ptra in a load he
scores Matt potra pots another is third in his
last two games and it's two nothing Bruins the
SP in the middle of the Isis this is really strong
work by ptra to stay with Cory Perry and then he
takes it to his forehand around the left pad
of Peter moraza protect the [Applause] pot
and no goals a couple of days ago now he's
got three as he slides this by morzak an
unassisted goal for Matt po ra and it's two
nothing Boston I talk to your brother-in-law
Tony Granado former terrific player and coach
now working with the Blackhawks television in
their Studio talked in between periods you know
that's really a tough challenge right I mean
this is still the very young Chicago team and
they're playing a bunch of men in this Boston
Unit here's Coyle snapped it on net rebound
man re they put it out in front and they score
again
[Applause] two goals just 56 Seconds Apart
Ben reite chips the puck past Conor Murphy
Murphy's now without a stick so he's really
not of much use and before the help can get
back from kachuk or from kajuk rather J jvr
chips it out in front and driven in by forber
and Ray this Chicago team still with a
lot of work to do on the rebuild they
have some uh prospects in college hockey and
Junior Hockey they have a lot of draft picks
coming but you'd have to think it's
a long shot for them to be a playoff
Contender this year I I really I don't think
that's even possible I don't think it's in
their Wildest Dreams really but here's Bard
with a Chance late centers one went through
Curry Chev good chance one of the best
of the night for Chicago ler down to 6
seconds to go and Jeremy swan has his 10th
career shut up in just 91 regular season